WOJTEK KALICINSKI:
Android Studio 3.0
is finally ready for download
in the stable channel.
It brings about
many improvements
that will make developer
experience smoother,
but also some important changes
that might require attention.
Android Studio 3 is
the first release
in which we've added Kotlin
support out of the box,
and we turn on fully
supporting it going forward.
Kotlin is a fun and
expressive language
that has grown popular
with Android developers.
Thanks to high interoperability
with existing Java code,
you can now immediately
start using it in your apps.
We continue to support the
Java programming language,
and with the newest
Android Gradle plugin,
we're enabling developers to
use Java 8 language features
in their code and libraries.
We have built bytecode
transformations called desugar
into the default
toolchain, and it
supports lambdas, method
references, default
and static interface methods,
and try-with resources,
and new annotation
types on all API levels.
The experimental Jack compiler
is now deprecated and migrating
is as simple as removing
it from your build files.
With the new Android
Gradle plugin version 3,
we are also bringing
performance enhancements
to the build process, such as
delayed dependency resolution,
more incremental dexing,
and faster sync times.
We're also bringing
variant awareness
for library modules,
which unfortunately
meant we had to make some
breaking changes to our Gradle
DSL.
So please follow the migration
steps in the documentation
when switching to 3.0.
Especially developers with
large multi-module projects
should see a
significant decrease
in build times
with these changes.
Starting with this
release, we are
switching to AAPT2 for
resource processing, which
enables more incremental and
parallelized builds and even
some potential size savings
in the resources file
without any changes
required to your projects,
thanks to automatic version
collapsing, resource
deduplication, and support for
sparse configurations on minSdk
26.
On the IDE side,
we're making changes
to help developers bring Android
Oreo features to their apps.
We've added support for font
resources, which you can now
create and preview in the
Fonts Resource folder.
The Layout Editor also
lets you pick fonts
from the Google Fonts
catalog and attach them
to your projects.
For creating adaptive
launcher icons introduced
in Android Oreo,
open the Asset Studio
and select the foreground
and background images
that you'd like to use.
We've also included
Android emulator images
running Android Oreo so
you can test your changes.
To make it easier to set
up and maintain CI servers,
we have also launched
Google's Maven Repo as a place
where we distribute
Google's build artifacts.
You can start using it
by adding the Maven Repo
URL to your Gradle files.
Debugging performance
problems with your apps
is also about to
get a lot better,
thanks to the new unified
Android Profiler in Studio.
It lets you inspect CPU,
memory, and network usage,
and includes a
single timeline that
also shows important app events,
such as keypresses, taps,
and rotations.
With advanced profiling,
you can record CPU traces,
track object
allocations, and dig
into heap dumps in
the memory profiler
And this is completely
new, by the way--
you can show request
and response information
and payloads for HTTP
calls that were made using
one of the supported clients.
For now, we support
HttpURLConnection and OkHttp,
as well as any client
using these under the hood.
If you're writing C or
C++ code in another IDE,
or perhaps you're
using other tools,
such as game engine
toolkits, to build your APK,
you can now use Android Studio
native debugger with your app.
Open the APK for
debugging, attach the debug
symbols and sources,
and you will
be able to step through code
just as with an app developed
inside Studio.
3.0 is the first
release to support
creation of Instant Apps
from your Android projects.
There are two new module types--
Instant App and Feature.
Together with a new
refactoring system,
they help modularize your
app, while the App Links
Assistant helps set up the
necessary App Links support.
If you run into any problems
when testing Instant
App builds, we've
updated the APK analyzer
to open zip bundles.
But that's not all.
APK analyzers DEX
Viewer now supports
loading ProGuard mapping files
to show removed and retained
classes and can generate
ProGuard keep rules.
It also has an improved user
interface showing DEX code
sizes, lets you
explore method usages,
inspect bytecode, and
supports multidex.
Starting with
BuildTools 26.1, you
can also get all these features
in the brand new command line
version of the APK
Analyzer, which
is great for generating
reports and tracking APK size
regressions on a CI server.
When working with layouts,
you can now iterate faster
using the Layout Editor
and Layout Inspector, which
are both getting some updates.
The Editor includes
a new error panel
showing problems such as
missing constraints, and support
for new constraint
layout features,
such as barriers, groups,
and enhanced chains creation.
And the Inspector
received a UI refresh
and Quick Search for the
Properties list and the View
Tree.
If you need to pull files
from a device or emulator,
try the Device File Explorer,
a much more user friendly way
to browse the connected
file system than using adb
from a command line.
We've also had some important
improvements in the Android
Emulator since the
last release of Studio,
and that includes
new system images
with full Play
Store, OpenGL ES 3.0
compatibility, a proxy settings
page, and a bug reporting tool.
There are many, many new things
to play with in this release
of Android Studio.
Have fun exploring,
and check out
the other videos detailing
some of the features
in this release.